welcome back to las vegas now when life
gives you lemons
you learn legal terms eric palacios and
eric from eric velocio's and associates
the sponsors of this next segment tells
us how to how to know when your car is a
lemon check it out
i'm eric colasios and welcome to this
week's legal minute the question we have
is how do i know if my car is a lemon
you need to keep three things in mind
number one to be a lemon you must have
purchased your car new and you must have
the same problem with it at least four
times during a one year period or within
the warranty period or if your car was
out of service for at least 30 days
straight then it can also be classified
as a lemon number two what can you do if
this is the case you can return it to
the dealership and ask for a refund or
you can ask the dealer to exchange it
for a similar car
the dealer cannot refuse one of these
two options
number three what will happen to your
car after that
your car has to be rebranded as a lemon
before it's sold again
this has been the legal minute don't
forget to download my free app eric
palacio's legal app we'll see you next
week
for more information give eric palacios
and associates a call that number is
702-444-7777